okay the good news is it's Roberto
Benigni
the bad news is he's had nine espressos
I got you covered ladies and gentlemen
he got past the arm restraints here he
is Roberto Benigni
there goes
you everywhere this is a one of this
wonderful moment there I wish I
possessed a tail I could walk in order
to demonstrate my joy to be I would like
to be a dog really a dog to lumbering
and flittering a feckless a to jump in
everybody to leak and to demonstrate my
joy to everybody but I cannot because
since my acceptance speech last year
they asked me to stay the hell off the
furniture so here are the nominees I am
presenting five wonderful women oh yeah
I know I know I know I realize here are
the nominees for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role
Annette Bening
in American Beauty
Janet McTeer in tumbleweeds
in the end of their fare Meryl Streep
huh
Hilary Swank in ice don't cry
and they'll scatter girls do he let his
swag
when first Oscar nomination she lived as
a boy for one month to prepare for the
role of Teena Brandon a true story of a
boy girl living as a boy in the class
thank you thank you so much we have come
a long way to think that this movie
wouldn't have been made three and a half
years ago and we made it now for under 2
million dollars and now this it's quite
remarkable I want to thank the Academy
for their support and recognition of me
and my work in a movie that is so
important and I am so proud to be a part
of it this movie would have never been
made I had I just on the off chance that
I got up here I brought this piece of
paper because I knew I couldn't forget
anyone because everyone put their heart
and soul into this movie and God knows
no one got paid so first kimberly peirce
for her fierce tenacity and vision andy
being in our co-writer killer films you
guys always make important movies and i
thank you for that
john hart jeff sharp for being there for
me every single minute jim to know our
cinematographer who was absolutely
brilliant Carrie Barden Jennifer
McNamara for fighting for me
the casting directors Chloe Sevigny the
rest of the cast who portrayed their
character so honestly and brilliantly
Lee Percy our editor I want to thank
Michael Stremme 'el Lindsey Law and Bill
mechanic and everyone at Fox Searchlight
for putting their wing around this small
little movie and giving us wings Larry
Moss my acting coach who without him I
could have never given this performance
Thank You Larry
my mom who's up there somewhere it looks
like living out of our car was worth it
Holly Hine for keeping my head on
straight my publicist Roy Nankin who is
a beautiful beautiful human being a care
F cami Putnam I have to thank you for
fighting from me
I'm almost and I promise the independent
film channel for helping us finish our
movie and he'll Derek wheelie and David
workshafter for their support and last
but certainly not least I want to thank
Brandon Teena for being such an
inspiration to us all his legacy lives
on through our movie to remind us to
always be ourselves to follow our hearts
to not conform I pray for the day when
we not only accept our differences but
we actually celebrate our diversity
thank you very much
you